it is time for drew's news and with me
at the desk
is the best co-pilot a girl could ever
ask for ross matthews
hi everybody thank you hi
oh i'm so happy to be here i love you
how's your day going you know what great
it's cold out there i walked to work
this morning i brought you a little
something i'll show you in a second you
got to wait for it really yes
i did oh i love when you bring things
yeah i'm surprised excited okay good all
right um well first up why don't we talk
about spider-man no way home oh my gosh
yes
excited is very exciting because it's
gonna be a big boost to the you know
movie theater economy comes out this
friday everyone's gonna flock and freak
and it's the third movie starring tom
holland as the hero who is
literally one of the most talented human
beings and then when you think about
who's the most talented man well gosh
who's the most talented women woman
zendaya
of course and
we all know that they're a couple
and um
you know i just love them as a couple so
much so cute right they were in the i
love when couples fall in love on the
movie set and then it really works in
real life yeah i'm invested you know
what i mean yeah no i know it's like a
it's like it's a fantasy come to reality
totally but a lot of what's making
headlines as they're doing press all
over the world is their height
difference
so yahoo life reports that zendaya said
she never thought about it her mom is
taller than her dad and tom thinks the
whole thing is ridiculous and he
admitted to gq recently that he's had to
fight through insecurities about his
height they kiss in the new movie
without cheating on an apple box which
is what they do to like lift you up and
get you at eye level and they say
they're glad to break the old stigmas
that are still hanging around about like
a man is supposed to be taller than the
woman rossi thought this is ridiculous
you know they still you know when you go
to the carnival it's like you must be
this tall to ride this ride do you have
to be this tall to date zendaya no leave
it with the carnies
i i would rather have a good man who was
a little short than have a tall man who
had a short temper you know what i'm
saying
who cares
well and there are these amazing couples
throughout the year who have a height
difference and we ate it up with a spoon
keith urban and nicole kidman look at
that yeah and there's that's right oh my
goodness iman and david bowie it's so
gorgeous does it get any better than
that when charlize uh theron dated sean
penn she towered over him
um my bestie cameron diaz and her
husband benji look at her look at them
yeah yeah i i don't think height is one
of your battles you should pick in a
relationship all right hey next up it is
the holiday season are you in the mood
everyone yeah
yeah oh yeah i went you know where i
went uh this weekend that really got me
in the holiday mood i went and saw the
rockettes here at radio city music
oh
i'm like i wanna oh i'm all about it now
i missed my calling drew i should have
been a rossette it's true and i dare you
not to be in the holiday mood if you get
a little rockettes on you but okay so um
it's also the time for everyone is doing
what the christmas cards right now the
holiday cards oh yeah well if it's
causing you some stress take a page out
of reese witherspoon's holiday handbook
the site she knows reports rhys posted
her card for the season and it features
her and her pups and she captioned it
when you can't wrangle the crew for a
holiday card just get the dogs right
yeah yeah i know because that's always
such a thing when you get the kids and
they all have to be looking forward
right at the right click do you do a
holiday card um i i do i did it one year
and my daughters asked this year they
were like mom why haven't we done our
holiday card yeah and i was like oh
because i'm hanging by a thread
just trying to get to the end of the
year but yeah we should get on top of
that yeah and then i was like it's not
happening this year um but uh
reece is coming on the show uh next week
oh yeah and she is someone um that i
have a lifelong bond with we've been
friends since we were 13.
and her son tennessee and my daughter
olive were born on the same day wow i
wonder if you'll get one of our holiday
cards guess what
i brought
my christmas card to give to you i
haven't sent this out yet you're the
first person i'm giving it to
oh rossi
i'm already so emotional this could
really make me cry
look at us there's valentine's day god
it is you and wellington
look at the back too bye oh
i'm sorry i'm not going to have this
kind of game this year but you're going
to give me goals this rossi is just
everything congratulations
on wellington thank you
getting your card out on time and
yeah maybe maybe i maybe i have enough
time to send out a holiday card no no i
know we never mind okay up next well i
know something that is going to get you
really excited
uh we've got a mac and cheese headline
for you
yes
her favorite food
people reports that gal gadot and her
husband jeroen barcano have created a
new take on that boxed mac and cheese we
love so much they call theirs goodles uh
wonder woman's taking a break from
saving the world the world peace to
bring us a healthier mac and cheese
thank you gal gadot the noodles are made
from wheat flour and nutrients and real
veggies like broccoli and spinach and
drew's already eating it take a look
she's taking a bite
drew what do you think so i saw gal
gadot on social media
making this and this stuff is like back
ordered
um so it's
plant-based and there's vegetables
within the noodles
but here's what i gathered when i
watched her making it and started
salivating and have dreamt of this
moment ever since understood it tastes
like real mac and cheese it doesn't give
you that weird i'm compromising it's
organic it's healthy stop jerking my
chain
this is what macaroni and cheese is
supposed to taste like she totally
nailed it and i'm sorry this is made
with
what
what i want is a mac and cheese that gal
gadot makes with broccoli and carrots
i'm basically eating a salad thank you
thank you dough
i
i want this is what i want this is so
incredible
um gal gadot
i remember when you stepped on to the
stage when you were the new wonder woman
and i just thought they got it so right
with you
you're every woman
you are in the army you're a mother
you're gorgeous you're capable
you represent what a woman should be
and i am just one of your biggest fans
and now you brought macaroni and cheese
into it i mean that's what we thought
she couldn't get better
what can't you do
[Music]
you